imagine were asked to approximate the
area between the x-axis and the graph of
F from x equals 1 to x equals 10 using a
right Riemann sum with three equal
subdivisions to do that we are given a
table of values for F so I encourage you
to pause the video and see if you can
come up with an approximation for the
area between the x-axis and the graph
from x equals 1 to x equals 10 using a
right Riemann sum with three equal
subdivisions so I'm assuming you had a
go at it so now let's try to do that
together and this is interesting because
we don't have a graph of the entire
function but we just have the value of
the function at certain points but as
you'll see this is all we need in order
to get an approximation for the area we
don't know how close it is to the actual
area with just these points but it'll
give us at least a right Riemann sum for
the approximation or an approximation
using a right Riemann sum so let me just
draw some axes here because whenever I
do Riemann sums you can do them without
graphs but it helps to think about
what's going on if you can visualize it
graphically so let's see we are going
from x equals 1 to x equals 10 so this
is 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 and so they give
us the value of f of x when x equals 1
when x equals 2 3 4 when x equals 7 5 6
7 8 9 10 and x equals 10 and they tell
us that when X is 1 we're at 6 and we go
to 8 2 3 5 so let me mark these off so
we're going to go up to 8 so 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 and so what we know when X is equal
to 1 F of 1 is 6 so this is this is 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 so this point right over
here is f of 1 is this is the point 1
comma 6 and then we have the point 4
comma 8 4 comma 8
we'll put us right about there and then
we have seven comma three is on our
graph y equals x f of X so seven comma
three would put us right over there and
then we have ten comma five so ten comma
five put us right over there
that's all we know about the function we
don't know exactly what it looks like
our function might look like this it
might do something like this
whoops I drew a part that didn't look
like a function it might do something
like this and oscillate
really quickly it might do it might be
nice and smooth and just kind of go and
do something just like that kind of a
connect-the-dots we don't know but we
can still do the approximation using a
right Riemann sum with three equal
subdivisions how do we do that well
we're thinking about the area from x
equals 1 to x equals 10 so let me make
those boundaries clear so this is from x
equals 1 to x equals 10 and what we what
we want to do is have three equal
subdivisions
and there's three very natural
subdivisions here if we make each of our
subdivisions three wide so this could be
a subdivision and then this is another
subdivision and we do a Riemann sums you
don't have to have equal subdivisions
although that's what you'll often see so
we've just divided going from one to ten
to three equal sections that are three
wide so that's three this is 3 and this
is 3 and so the question is how do we
define the height of these subdivisions
which are going to end up being
rectangles and that's where the right
Riemann sum applies if we were doing a
left Riemann sum we would use the left
boundary of each of the subdivisions and
the value of the function there to
define the height of the rectangle so
this would be doing a left Riemann sum
but we're doing a right Riemann sum so
we use the right boundary of each of
these subdivisions to define the height
so our right boundary is when x equals 4
for this first section what is f of 4
it's 8 so we're going to use that as the
height of our of this first rectangle
that's approximating the area for this
part of the curve similarly for this
second one since we're using a right
Riemann sum we use the value of the
function at the right boundary the right
boundary 7 so the value of the function
is 3 so this would be our second
rectangle our second division I guess I
used to approximate the area and then
last but not least we would use the
right boundary of this third subdivision
when x equals 10 f of 10 is 5 so just
like that and so then our right riemann
approximation using our right Riemann
sum with three equal subdivisions to
approximate the area we would just add
the area of these rectangles so this
first rectangle let's see it is three
wide and how high is it well the height
here is f of 4 which is 8 so this is
going to be 24 square units whatever the
units happen to be this is going to be 3
times the height here is 3 f of 7 is 3
so that is 9 square units and then here
this is 3 the width is 3 times the
height F of 10 is 5 so 3 times 5 which
gets us 15 and so our approximation of
the area would be summing these 3 values
up so this would be 24 plus let's see 9
plus 15 would be give us another 24 so
it's 24 plus 24 it gets us to 48 there
you go we just using that table of
values we've been able to find an
approximation now once again we don't
know how good of an approximation is it
depends on what the function is doing
there's a world where it could be a very
good approximation
maybe the function does something like
this maybe the function just happens let
me make it a little bit maybe the
function does something like this where
in this case what we just did would be a
very good approximation or maybe the
function does something like this where
in this situation this might be a
bad approximation but we can at least do
the approximation using a right Riemann
sum just using this table